You started your Presidency in 1992.
Andy and I started doing this show in 1993
and so I have some appreciation for, in that span of time,
how much things have changed.
Now, you were out there campaigning hard last year
at this time, you probably, I'm curious:
did you think you saw a different America
than the one that you had seen
when you were campaigning back in 1992?
Do you think we have profoundly changed since then?
Yes and no, that is I think the good news is,
and I know it's hard to see and was totally unfashionable
to talk about in 2016, but, the country is much more diverse
than it used to be, and I think that's a good thing.
(audience applauds)
We are still, compared to other wealthy countries
relatively young, and having lost it,
I can tell you youth matters.
(audience laughs)
That is, the median age of the workforce is a big deal
in terms of the economic potential of a country.
So in a sense, the birth rate of native-born Americans
of all races is just barely at replacement level.
We need immigrants to come in
(audience applauds)
and keep diversifying the country and helping us grow.
(audience cheers and applauds)
But that's better, now.
So the thing that's not so good is that
we're in the middle of--
Trump!
Of revolution, yeah,
(audience laughs)
Well there is that.
Excuse me, I'm sorry, sir, we know.
(audience laughs)
Believe me I know, especially today.
But anyway, we're in the middle of this transition
of how we get our information, how we communicate,
and the pattern of economic growth has heavily favored
people with more education and heavily favored
people without regard to their education level
if they live in or around cities that are growth centers.
So for example in the last election,
President Trump won all these rural counties.
They comprised, he got 46% of the vote.
They comprised 36% of the GDP of the country.
The counties Hillary carried comprised 64% of the GDP
of the country, even though the median income
of a Trump voter was slightly higher
than the median income of a Hillary voter.
The people who voted for her were people
who were hopeful about the future,
believed in the assets of the country,
believed we could grow together and go together,
and we're somehow--
(audience applauds)
And we're basically more resistant to the bizarre nature
of the way the election was covered.
They just looked at the debates and they looked
at the conventions and they made a choice,
and so I think that all of us have to do
is no matter how happy some of us are
about what happened yesterday in the elections,
we have to remember that the founders told us
our job was to create a more perfect union,
so we have to bridge these economic divides,
just like we ask the people on the other side
of the social divide to help us bridge the social divide.
We have to create inclusive economics,
inclusive societies, and we need an inclusive culture.
(audience applauds)
And then,
we need to tell all these people
that just make up stuff on the internet
to knock it off, that we're voting for people
who are going to do jobs, these are jobs,
and as soon as somebody gets one of these jobs,
you find out pretty quick that the decisions
they make have consequences, that affects people's lives.
And so it matters what you know and even more important,
it matters how you think.
Whether you're conservative or liberal,
do you believe this is an interdependent age,
and we can't escape each other,
then you gotta decide, which is more important,
our interesting differences, or our common humanity,
and that's the conclusion I draw,
but it is different and it's way better in some ways,
and much more troubling in some ways.
And the dictators' club in the world,
and there's a bunch of 'em you know, they want two things.
They want nuclear weapons because they feel like
they can never be dislodged no matter how much
people hate 'em if they got nuclear power,
and they want to abolish the line between fact and fiction
and truth and lie because they figure if you don't know
what's true and you don't think you can ever know,
that pretty soon everybody will accept the fact
that democracy's no longer possible.
Right, you're talking about foreign countries now,
or here, 'cause that's (laughing)
(audience laughs)
That shook me to the bone for a second,
I thought we were in Korea.
(audience laughs)
Look, all I can tell you is--
You just said a lot
by saying nothing.
No, but look at the effort
here to disenfranchised voters, to make it harder
for young people, for people of color,
for the elderly, infirm, who are poor and vulnerable,
for all kinds of people to vote.
The reason there's no immigration reform
is because the people who are against it are afraid
it would adversely affect their electoral prospects,
if more people who work and pay taxes could also vote.
And when the Supreme Court gutted the Voting Rights Act,
they made a terrible mistake because it unleashed
all these efforts to basically try to shrink the electorate.
But those of you who don't like it
should own some responsibility
if you have ever missed a midterm election.
(audience applauds)
Because that's when
most of the governors are elected, that's mhen most
of the secretary or the legislators are elected,
so we all got to own up, we need to just go out
and start going up to people who are mad at us
and say, "Look let's get over it,
"we've got to live together,
"we've got to share this together and if we work together,
"we'll have better economics, we'll have better societies,
"and we'll have a culture that we can all be a part of."
(audience applauds and cheers)